after being publicly humiliated Again by
his apparently estranged wife he
responds by blaming himself and his
emotional blindness so he's the one
who's emotionally
blind she is just ripping him the shreds
in public constantly no concern for his
own emotions that she's the one who
brings him on camera to talk about her
affair while he sits there clearly like
on the verge of tears it's an utterly
Broken Man and she doesn't notice or
doesn't care or both
um and yet Will Smith says that he's the
one who is emotionally blind and then he
extols Jada's hidden nuances and subtle
Beauties and it's true by the way I
don't deny that if Jada pinket Smith has
any beauty it is very subtle